[Applause]
spirits were high at this convention
center in sao paulo thousands gathered
to hear brazil's former president
louisiana silva as he promised to defeat
incumbent jair bolsonaro in october's
election
mulla announced that his candidacy has
the support of trade unions social
organizations and seven center-left
parties including his own workers party
he compared his two-term presidency of
latin america's largest democracy to
that of bolsonaro an admirer and
follower of former u.s president donald
trump
brazil is too big to be an international
pariah because we are submissive because
we are denialists and because we attack
our greatest commercial partners causing
enormous damage to our economy
brazil will hold general elections in
five months as the country deals with
record two-digit yearly inflation high
interest rates and unemployment
brazil is back on the united nations
hunger map which it had left in 2014 for
the first time in its history
rula also appealed to young voters
promising to protect the amazon the
environment and brazil's indigenous
people
recent polls show lula having the
support of more than 40 percent of the
population and jai bolsonaro in second
place with more than 30 percent
but lula supporters are anxious they
know the tables can turn at any moment
there is no guarantee that we will be
victorious we are very much at risk of
having brazilians re-elect bolsonaro's
fascist government this is a historic
moment when progressive forces unite to
fight evil but anything can happen
bolsonaro has the support of brazil's
powerful farm lobby of the christian
right and of brazilians who were
disappointed with lula and with the
corruption scandals involving him and
his workers party
but bolsonaro is also being accused of
incompetence and mismanagement of the
kovit-19 crisis which has killed more
than
660 000 brazilians
officially the electoral campaign in
brazil
starts on august the 15th but both lula
and the current president bolsonaro are
already fighting for every single vote
they can get in what promises to be a
very polarized election
monica yanagiv al jazeera so far